From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. And I want to tell you about two police investigations. One of them is done so inspiringly well, it's like the detectives in it are like detectives on a television show-- smart and resourceful and great judgment and just police at their very best. The other case-- the same crime, lots of the same facts-- is the opposite. It goes terribly.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》节目，我是艾拉·格拉斯。我想向大家讲述两起警方调查。其中一起调查非常出色，侦探们如同电视剧里的人物一样——聪明、足智多谋、判断力极佳，展现了警察的最佳风范。而另一起案件——同样的犯罪、许多相同的事实——却截然相反，结果极其糟糕。
And the investigation that goes wrong goes wrong in a very unusual way. It's like a game of telephone, where one misunderstanding begets another misunderstanding begets another, until something that is not true spreads to an entire community of people and somehow hardens into the truth. And it happens incredibly fast. It happens in just three days.
而且那起出错的调查，出错的方式非常离奇。这就像是在玩传声筒游戏，一个误解引出另一个误解，再引出下一个，直到某种不实的消息传遍了整个群体，并以某种方式被当作了事实。这一切发生得快得惊人，仅仅用了三天时间。
And just to get in front of this, the crime that we're going to be talking about this hour is a sexual assault. If that's a trigger for you, consider this a warning. And one of the first phone calls in this chain comes right after the crime. This is back in August, 2008. A woman named Shannon was standing on her balcony in a Seattle suburb when she got the phone call. It was from an 18-year-old she knew named Marie, who told her she'd been woken up in the night by a stranger who raped her.
在进入正题之前，我先说明，本期节目要谈论的犯罪是一起性侵案。如果这触动了您的心理创伤，请将此视为预警。案发后不久，调查链条中的第一通电话就打来了。那是 2008 年 8 月，一个叫香农的女人当时正站在西雅图郊区的阳台上，她接到了这通电话。电话是她认识的一位 18 岁女孩玛丽打来的，玛丽告诉她，自己在夜里被一个闯入的陌生人强奸了。
And I asked her, are you OK? And she said she was OK and that she was going to be staying, I think, with a friend that night. And when my husband got home, I told him what had happened. But I said, I don't know that it happened.
我问她：“你还好吗？”她说她还好，我想那天晚上她会和朋友待在一起。当我丈夫回家时，我告诉了他发生的事情。但我说：“我不知道这是否真的发生了。”
There's something about how she said it that just made me question whether or not she'd actually been raped. It was the tone of her voice. There was just no emotion. It was like she was telling me that she'd made a sandwich. I just made myself a chicken sandwich.
她说话的方式让我不由得怀疑她是否真的被强奸了。那是她的语调，没有任何情绪波动。听起来就像她在告诉我她做了一个三明治一样。我刚做了一个鸡肉三明治。
Shannon felt awful doubting Marie. She'd known Marie for years. Marie was a foster child who had stayed with Shannon and her husband very briefly-- just a couple weeks-- when she was younger. And they'd all hit it off. And she stayed close with Marie even after Marie went to live in another foster home. They'd hang out together, cook together. They gave up carbs together for a few weeks.
香农为怀疑玛丽感到难过。她认识玛丽很多年了。玛丽曾是一个寄养孩子，早些年曾在香农和她丈夫家短暂住过几周。他们很投缘。即使在玛丽搬到另一个寄养家庭后，他们依然保持着密切联系。他们一起玩，一起做饭。他们还曾一起断碳水饮食几周。
Shannon loved Marie. She saw herself in Marie. They were alike in lots of ways. That was actually part of her doubt. Marie was emotional. She did cry, like Shannon.
香农很爱玛丽。她在玛丽身上看到了自己的影子。她们在很多方面都很像。事实上，这也是她产生怀疑的原因之一。玛丽是个情绪化的人。她像香农一样，也会哭。
If I had been raped, I would have been hysterical. I would have been crying, really upset because I was sexually abused as a child. And I was sexually assaulted as an adult. And I never told anyone for years and years. And when I did tell someone, I was hysterical, emotional and crying and shamed.
如果我被强奸了，我会歇斯底里的。我会哭，会非常难过，因为我小时候曾受过性虐待，成年后也曾遭到性侵。我多年来从未告诉过任何人。当我终于告诉别人时，我是歇斯底里、情绪激动、哭泣并感到羞愧的。
But Shannon was wrong about Marie. Marie had been raped. It was proven later beyond a shadow of a doubt. And the way her case went wrong-- you know, we've all heard stories about police not believing women who come forward and say that they were sexually assaulted. But in this case, the doubts began not with the police but with people much closer to Marie, people who love her and have the best intentions towards her.
但香农对玛丽的判断错了。玛丽确实被强奸了。后来毫无疑问地证实了这一点。至于她的案件是如何出错的——你知道，我们都听说过警察不相信受害者报案的故事。但在本案中，怀疑的开始并非来自警方，而是来自与玛丽关系更亲近的人，那些爱她并对她怀有最好意愿的人。
What goes wrong in this case is something so personal, it's like people exercising empathy and getting it wrong. And then that mistake spreads to officials and friends and acquaintances until it is impossible for them all to see the truth, even when new proof comes to light, even when it's all right there in front of them.
这起案件出错的原因非常私人化，就像是人们在试图共情时却用错了地方。然后，这个错误蔓延到官员、朋友和熟人身上，以至于即使在新的证据出现、事实就摆在眼前时，他们也无法看清真相。
Our reporting today is a partnership with The Marshall Project and ProPublica. The first part of the story takes place mostly in Lynnwood, Washington, near Seattle. Marshall Project investigative reporter Ken Armstrong and one of our producers, Robyn Semien, will explain how all this unfolded, starting with Ken, who'll explain a little more about Marie.
我们今天的报道是与《马歇尔计划》和《ProPublica》合作完成的。故事的第一部分主要发生在华盛顿州林伍德，靠近西雅图。《马歇尔计划》调查记者肯·阿姆斯特朗和我们的制作人罗宾·塞米恩将解释这一切是如何发展的，首先由肯来详细介绍一下玛丽。
Marie gets along with people. She's good at it. It's important to her. She moved around a lot when she was a kid in the foster care system-- she thinks 10 or 11 different families, not including group homes. But she did well in a group, looked forward to high school, loved her classes, liked to hike and go to the beach with her friends, really got into photography.
玛丽很善于与人相处。她很擅长这个，这对她来说很重要。她在寄养系统中长大，经常搬家——她认为大约换了 10 或 11 个不同的家庭，还不算集体寄宿点。但她在集体生活中表现良好，很期待高中生活，热爱课程，喜欢和朋友远足、去海滩，对摄影非常着迷。
At 18, she was proud of herself for surviving the foster care system, got a job at Costco, her own apartment.
18 岁时，她为自己能从寄养系统中生存下来而感到自豪，在好市多找了份工作，有了自己的公寓。
It was just nice to be on my own and not have all the rules that I had had when being in foster care. And it was just like freedom. So it was just awesome.
能独立生活，不再受我在寄养期间必须遵守的所有规矩约束，这种感觉真好。那简直就像自由。所以那真是太棒了。
She kept in touch with previous foster families, like Shannon and her last foster mom, Peggy. Shannon was the fun adult in Marie's life. They were goofballs together. They'd have sleepovers at Shannon's house, laugh a lot. Peggy, who'd been Marie's foster mom from 16 to 18, was more serious and teacherly, more tough love, more worried about Marie's big personality and free spirit getting in the way of Marie's becoming a responsible young adult.
她与之前的寄养家庭保持着联系，比如香农和她最后的寄养妈妈佩吉。香农是玛丽生命中那个有趣的成年人。她们在一起总是傻里傻气的。她们会在香农家过夜，开怀大笑。佩吉在玛丽 16 到 18 岁时担任她的寄养妈妈，她更严肃、更有教导意味，管教更严厉，更担心玛丽那张扬的个性和自由的灵魂会阻碍她成为一名负责任的年轻成年人。
Peggy lived close, and on the morning of the assault, Peggy was the first adult Marie called. This is Peggy.
佩吉住得很近，在袭击发生的当天早上，佩吉是玛丽打给的第一个成年人。这是佩吉。
It was so early in the morning, I just left, and I drove over there immediately. So the police were there. And Marie was sitting on the floor crying. I sat down next to her, and she was telling me what happened. And I got this-- I'm a big Law and Order fan. And I just got this really weird feeling. It was like-- I felt like she was telling me the script of a Law and Order story.
那时候太早了，我直接出发，立刻开车赶了过去。警察已经在那里了。玛丽坐在地板上哭。我坐在她旁边，她告诉我发生了什么。我有了一种——我是《法律与秩序》的忠实粉丝。我有一种非常奇怪的感觉。感觉就像是——我觉得她像是在复述《法律与秩序》的剧本。
She was detached. Detached. Emotionally detached from what she was saying. It felt like, just, what's this drama going on? But still, there was a part of me that was like, oh, my God. I mean, if it is real, I need to respond.
她很超脱。超脱。她在情感上与自己所说的事情脱节了。感觉就像，这到底是什么闹剧？但内心深处，我仍然有一部分想，天哪。我的意思是，如果这是真的，我需要做出回应。
I remember being in shock and shaking in a blanket in the corner. They asked me a few questions about what had happened, and I had told them I'd left my door unlocked and that someone had broken into my apartment and raped me.
我记得自己当时处于震惊之中，裹着毯子躲在角落里发抖。他们问了我几个关于发生什么的问题，我告诉他们我忘了锁门，有人闯进我的公寓强奸了我。
Again, this is Marie. She's 25 now. A quick warning-- what she told police is difficult to hear and definitely not for kids. Here's what happened-- Marie was home by herself, and she was awake all night talking on the phone with her ex-boyfriend, Jordan.
再次说明，这是玛丽。她现在 25 岁。快速预警——她告诉警察的内容难以入耳，绝对不适合孩子听。发生了什么事——玛丽独自在家，整晚没睡，一直在和前男友乔丹通电话。
I got off the phone and went to sleep and then opened my eyes, and there was somebody in my house. He had a knife in his hand and was wearing a mask. He blindfolded me and gagged me and tied my hands behind my back.
我挂了电话睡着了，然后睁开眼，屋子里就有个人。他手里拿着刀，戴着面具。他蒙住我的眼睛，塞住我的嘴，把我的双手绑在身后。
He raped her. He went through her stuff. He took pictures. He knew her name. Marie prayed he wouldn't kill her.
他强奸了她。他翻遍了她的东西。他拍了照。他知道她的名字。玛丽祈祷他不要杀她。
And then, after he was done with everything, he said that I shouldn't have left my door unlocked. I guess I must have left it unlocked, the sliding glass door. And he just said that he was sorry and it all looked better in his head than when he did it to me.
然后，在他做完所有事情后，他说我不应该不锁门。我想我一定是没锁滑动玻璃门。他只是说他很抱歉，而且一切在他脑海里看起来比实际对他做的时候要好得多。
He said if she went to the police, he'd put the pictures he had of her online.
他说，如果她报警，他就把拍她的那些照片发到网上。
When the police arrived at Marie's apartment, they did what you'd expect-- they processed the crime scene. A crime scene technician snapped photos of the place. It didn't look like much, an 18-year-old's tidy, bare-bones apartment-- a sofa, a bike, a desktop computer on the floor in the corner. The bed was unmade, green comforter on the floor, a messy sheet.
警察到达玛丽的公寓时，他们做了预料中的事——勘查犯罪现场。现场技术员拍了照。现场看起来没什么特别的，一个 18 岁女孩整洁、陈设简陋的公寓——一张沙发、一辆自行车、角落地板上一台台式电脑。床铺没叠，绿色被子掉在地板上，床单很乱。
Marie was blindfolded, and her attacker wore a mask, so there wasn't a real description. He wore gloves to avoid fingerprints. He wore a condom. But there was physical evidence. The police got fingerprints off the sliding glass door. Just beyond the glass door, on the back porch, it looked like someone had brushed off a dusty railing while climbing over it.
玛丽被蒙着眼，袭击者戴着面具，所以没有明确的特征描述。他戴着手套以避开指纹。他戴了避孕套。但有物证。警方从滑动玻璃门上提取到了指纹。在玻璃门外的后廊上，看起来有人在翻越栏杆时拂去了上面的灰尘。
Police collected the bedding, hoping for DNA-- maybe fibers or hairs. Marie was examined by a doctor. There was a rape kit and a report noting bruising on both of Marie's wrists, plus other bruising and abrasions consistent with sexual activity. When police searched the apartment, they found the things Marie had said the man had used-- the knife, the makeshift blindfold and gag, the shoelaces used to tie her up with.
警方收集了寝具，希望能提取到 DNA——也许是纤维或毛发。医生检查了玛丽。有强奸取证包，报告记录了玛丽手腕上的淤青，以及其他与性行为相符的擦伤和淤伤。当警察搜查公寓时，他们发现了玛丽所说袭击者使用的东西——刀子、临时做的眼罩和口塞，以及用来绑她的鞋带。
That's when Marie realized that all of those things were hers to begin with. The knife was from her kitchen. The shoelaces came from her sneakers out in the living room.
就在那时，玛丽意识到所有这些东西最初都是她自己的。刀子来自她的厨房。鞋带来自她客厅里的运动鞋。
Peggy remembers hearing about the shoelaces and adding them to her list of things that just didn't make sense.
佩吉记得听到鞋带的事情时，便将其加入了她认为不合理的清单中。
And I just-- the whole thing with the shoelaces, I was like, first of all, is a shoelace strong enough to tie somebody's wrists with?
我当时就想——关于鞋带的整件事，首先，鞋带真的够结实到能绑住某人的手腕吗？
Then, that same day, Marie called several of her friends, not just her closest ones, to tell them about the rape. For Peggy, this behavior fit into a bigger picture she had of Marie-- attention-seeking, too flaunty, too flirty, loud, not really aware of how she was coming off in public. Like at the grocery store, riding around in carts with her friends, getting really silly, Peggy said.
然后，同一天，玛丽给她的几个朋友打了电话，不仅仅是最好的朋友，告诉她们强奸的事。对佩吉来说，这种行为符合她对玛丽一贯的印象——爱博关注、招摇、轻浮、大声喧哗，不太清楚自己在公共场合的表现如何。佩吉说，就像在超市里，和朋友们骑着购物车到处转，显得非常愚蠢。
Peggy was often telling Marie she needed to tone it down. So to Peggy, Marie calling everyone she knew and saying, "hey, I got raped," didn't seem right to her. She wondered, was this rape story one more way to get attention? Marie, meanwhile, says, sure. She was calling everyone she knew for what she thought was a good reason.
佩吉经常告诉玛丽她需要收敛一点。所以对佩吉来说，玛丽给所有认识的人打电话说“嘿，我被强奸了”看起来就不对劲。她纳闷，这强奸的故事是不是又一种寻求关注的方法？与此同时，玛丽说，当然是。她给所有认识的人打电话，因为她认为这有充分的理由。
I think I did that because I didn't want it to happen to anybody else. I just wanted to let people know that there was somebody out there hurting people. It wasn't the first time I had been raped-- when I was little and I was living with my mom. I never told anybody about that stuff, that it happened to me when I was a kid. I just held it all in and did my whole pretending like stuff didn't happen.
我想我这么做是因为我不希望这种事发生在别人身上。我只是想让人知道外面有一个人在伤害别人。这不是我第一次被强奸——我小时候和我妈妈住在一起时也被强奸过。我从未告诉过任何人那些事，关于我小时候发生的事。我只是把一切憋在心里，假装什么都没发生。
And, you know, I don't know if that guy ever got away or ended up hurting other people because I never told anybody, never talked to anybody about it. But I didn't want this time to be like that. I wanted to be able to try to talk about it and get it out.
而且，你知道，我不知道那个家伙是否逍遥法外或者伤害了其他人，因为我从未告诉任何人，从未和任何人谈论过。但我不想这次也一样。我想试着谈论它，把它发泄出来。
So Marie was calling around. And later that day-- or maybe it was the next morning-- Peggy made a phone call of her own, to Shannon, the other main adult in Marie's life. Here's Peggy.
所以玛丽四处打着电话。当天晚些时候——或者可能是第二天早上——佩吉自己也打了一通电话，打给了香农，玛丽生命中的另一位主要成年人。这是佩吉。
I just said, I don't know what the hell is going on. I can't tell, you know. I was like, oh, my God. She's telling me that she got raped. But I felt-- I just felt horrible. I felt horrible that I didn't believe her.
我只是说，我不知道到底发生了什么。我无法判断，你知道。我当时想，天哪。她说她被强奸了。但我感到——我感到非常糟糕。我因为不相信她而感到非常糟糕。
And so I think Shannon must have just picked up on that. And then she was like, Peggy, you're not the only one that doesn't believe her. She's acting very strange. She's telling everybody about it. She's calling everybody that she knows and telling them. This doesn't seem like what you would do.
所以我想香农一定捕捉到了这一点。然后她说：“佩吉，你不是唯一一个不相信她的人。她表现得很奇怪。她告诉了所有人。她给所有认识的人打电话说这件事。这看起来不像你会做的事。”
Shannon remembers that phone call with Peggy, too.
香农也记得与佩吉的那次通话。
Well, Peggy also didn't believe her. So looking back, we may have fed on each other's doubts about what had happened.
嗯，佩吉也不相信她。所以回想起来，我们可能在彼此怀疑发生了什么。
The day after the rape, Shannon helped Marie moved out of her apartment. Marie's case manager, who was helping her transition from foster care, was also there. And Shannon says that whole day, she kept noticing these things, little things, and each one deepened her suspicion.
强奸发生的第二天，香农帮玛丽搬出了公寓。玛丽的个案经理也到了场，他正在协助她从寄养系统过渡。香农说那整整一天，她不断注意到这些细节，一点一滴，每一件都加深了她的怀疑。
Marie wouldn't look her in the eye. She wouldn't hug her. She didn't want to talk about the rape. Instead, she was giggling, rolling around on the grass, being flirty, as Shannon saw it, with the case manager.
玛丽不敢直视她的眼睛。她不想拥抱她。她不想谈论强奸的事。相反，她一直在咯咯笑，在草地上打滚，在香农看来，她对个案经理表现得很轻浮。
For me, the thing that cemented my doubts was she was given, like, a Visa card to go pick out new sheets and bedding because the police had taken them for evidence. So we went back to the place where she had gotten the original ones. And she was furious that she couldn't buy the same set because she really liked it.
对我来说，让我确信疑点的，是她被给了一张 Visa 卡去买新床单和被褥，因为警察把原来的拿走作为证据了。所以我们回到了她买原来那套东西的地方。她因为不能买回同一套感到非常愤怒，因为她真的很喜欢那套。
I'm thinking, why would you want to have the same sheets and bedspread to look at every day when you'd been raped on this bed set? I said, why would you want to have those sheets to remind you? And she goes, because I like them. I just thought that was such a strange response.
我在想，既然在这张床上被强奸了，为什么还要买一模一样的床单和床罩每天看着呢？我说：“为什么你想要这些床单来提醒你？”她说：“因为我喜欢。”我只是觉得那反应太奇怪了。
That was the only time I saw her get mad the whole day.
那是我一整天唯一一次看到她发火。
Do you think you were starting to look for things that didn't ring true?
你觉得你当时是在寻找不真实的地方吗？
I don't know if I was looking for them. They just kept popping up. I mean, flirting with the manager and rolling in the grass and giggling.
我不知道我是否在刻意寻找。它们就是不断冒出来。我是说，和经理调情、在草地上打滚、咯咯笑。
Shannon confronted Marie about what she saw as her odd behavior.
香农就她认为的奇怪行为质问了玛丽。
I did. No, I told her that I had doubts about whether or not she was telling the truth.
我确实质问了。不，我告诉她，我怀疑她所说的是否属实。
And how did she react?
她有什么反应？
She would get upset. And she'd say, "you know, I'm not really a liar. Why would I lie about this thing?"
她会变得很难过。她说：“你知道，我真的不是个骗子。我为什么要拿这种事撒谎？”
Here's what I thought.
我是这么想的。
Again, this is Peggy. Peggy had her own theory for why Marie might be lying about this.
再次说明，这是佩吉。佩吉对玛丽为何可能撒谎有自己的理论。
I thought, OK. In my mind, Marie got herself into trouble. She got carried away with some kind of sexual encounter. And she let somebody take pictures of her. And now they're going to get out on the internet, and she's trying to backtrack.
我当时想，好吧。在我心里，玛丽给自己惹了麻烦。她卷入了一些性行为中，得意忘形了。她让某人拍了她的照片。现在照片要流传到网上了，她在试图推卸责任。
And maybe I didn't trust the police. And maybe I didn't think they were understanding the nature of my daughter's personality, you know? I mean, it's more histrionics, like a histrionic personality. It seemed like her next tactic to try to get my attention.
也许我不相信警察。也许我认为他们不了解我女儿的个性，你知道？我的意思是，这更像是歇斯底里，像是表演型人格。这看起来像是她试图博取我关注的下一个策略。
One day after the rape, Peggy called the lead detective on the case, Detective Jeffrey Mason.
强奸发生一天后，佩吉给负责该案的首席侦探杰弗里·梅森打了电话。
She asked if she could meet with me in person. And so I agreed, went to her residence, met with her. She was having questions about the story that was being told, whether it was truthful or not. She seemed, you know, sincere. She was trying to pass on information that-- and maybe sincere is not the correct terminology. But, I mean, she was just-- she expressed a lot of concern and caring for Marie but also had a lot of questions on whether she was reporting the truth or not.
她问能不能和我面谈。我同意了，去了她住的地方见了她。她对所讲述的故事有疑问，质疑其真实性。她看起来，你知道，很诚恳。她试图传递信息——也许“诚恳”这个词不对。但我的意思是，她只是——她对玛丽表达了很多关心和担忧，但同时也对她所说的内容是否属实有很多疑问。
Sergeant Mason didn't have a lot of experience investigating sexual assault. Marie's was only the second or third case that he'd worked on.
梅森警官调查性侵案的经验并不丰富。玛丽的案子是他经手的第二或第三起。
How much weight did you give Peggy's opinion of Marie's credibility or of the potential truthfulness of what Marie said had happened?
对于佩吉对玛丽可信度或玛丽所说内容真实性的判断，你有多大的参考？
I gave it enough weight to steer the investigation to where I need to talk to Marie further.
我给予了足够的参考来引导调查，让我觉得需要进一步找玛丽谈话。
Was there anything that you were using that was evidence-based to get you to this moment of wanting to talk to her again about her credibility?
有什么基于证据的东西让你走到这一步，想要重新询问她的可信度吗？
No.
没有。
Sergeant Mason says there were a few other elements to Marie's story that had caused him to question her. But it was really the call from Peggy that changed everything. He talks to his partner, and three days after the attack, Detective Mason calls Marie.
梅森警官说，玛丽的故事中还有其他几个因素让他产生了疑问。但真正改变一切的确实是佩吉打来的那通电话。他和搭档商量后，在袭击发生三天后，梅森侦探给玛丽打了电话。
And they said they needed to see me. And I just-- all of a sudden, I was just like, am I in trouble? That was my first-- before I said anything else on the phone. Am I in trouble?
他们说需要见我。我突然就想：我是有麻烦了吗？这是我挂掉电话前说的第一句话——我是有麻烦了吗？
One of the first things she said was, "am I in trouble?" And that just-- well, in the 25 years in law enforcement, my experience has been people that ask that are usually in trouble.
她说的第一件事是“我是有麻烦了吗？”而那——好吧，在 25 年的执法生涯中，我的经验是，问这个问题的人通常都是有麻烦的。
They said, well, we just need you to come into the police station.
他们说：“嗯，我们只是需要你来警察局。”
Mason and his partner, Detective Jerry Rittgarn, took Marie back to a conference room to talk. And it was a very different conversation from the first time police talked to Marie. Now it was an interrogation. She says the first thing they did was tell her they'd spoken to Peggy, and they'd spoken to her ex-boyfriend, Jordan, and neither of them believed her about being raped.
梅森和他的搭档杰瑞·里特加恩侦探把玛丽带到一个会议室谈话。这与第一次警察与玛丽谈话时完全不同。现在这是一场审讯。她说他们做的第一件事就是告诉她，他们和佩吉谈过，也和她的前男友乔丹谈过，他们谁都不相信她被强奸了。
Peggy was one thing, but Jordan was a friend. He and Marie spoke all the time. They talked about maybe getting back together. And he'd been supportive and sympathetic about the rape. Marie suddenly had to try and figure out what these detectives meant.
佩吉是一回事，但乔丹是个朋友。他和玛丽经常聊天。他们谈论过复合的事。而且他之前对强奸的事表示过支持和同情。玛丽突然不得不试图弄清楚这些侦探到底是什么意思。
The police were very closed off on telling me anything that Peggy or Jordan said. They wouldn't tell me anything that they said at all because he wanted me to tell him. And I couldn't. So he was just like, "yeah, is there any reason why he wouldn't believe you?" And I said, "I don't know."
警察对我非常封锁信息，不告诉我不论是佩吉还是乔丹说了什么。他们一点儿都不肯透露，因为他想让我自己交代。但我交代不出来。所以他就像：“是的，有什么理由他不相信你吗？”我说：“我不知道。”
We talked to Jordan, and he says he never doubted Marie, and he never told the police he did. In any case, both detectives wrote in their reports that Marie seemed unsure of her story. Detective Rittgarn wrote that he found Marie to be making, quote, "deceptive statements to include that she thought certain things had happened rather than she was positive that this happened." Rittgarn noted that she didn't, quote, "take a stand and demand that she had been raped." Detectives made it clear to Marie they needed to be convinced.
我们采访了乔丹，他说他从未怀疑过玛丽，也从未对警察说过他怀疑。无论如何，两位侦探都在报告中写道，玛丽对自己故事的真实性表现得不确定。里特加恩侦探写道，他发现玛丽在做，引用：“欺骗性陈述，包括她认为某些事情发生了，而不是肯定这些事情发生了。”里特加恩指出她没有，引用：“站稳立场坚持说自己被强奸了。”侦探们向玛丽表明，他们需要被说服。
Years later, there was an outside review of the case by a police investigator, a sex crime specialist named Sergeant Gregg Rinta. His report said, quote, "The manner in which she was treated by Sergeant Mason and Detective Rittgarn can only be labeled as bullying and coercive." Detective Rittgarn declined to talk to us.
多年后，警方调查员、性犯罪专家格雷格·林塔警官对该案进行了外部审查。他的报告称，引用：“梅森警官和里特加恩侦探对待她的方式只能被贴上霸凌和胁迫的标签。”里特加恩侦探拒绝接受我们的采访。
Sergeant Rinta's review went on, quote, "If this hadn't been documented in their reports, I would have been skeptical that this actually happened." The victim's credibility, quote, "became the focus of the investigation, and all of the strong evidence that pointed to a serious felony crime was completely ignored." Here's Marie.
林塔警官的审查报告继续写道，引用：“如果这些没有记录在他们的报告中，我会怀疑这是否真的发生过。”受害者的可信度，引用：“成为了调查的焦点，而所有指向严重重罪的有力证据都被完全忽略了。”这是玛丽。
Is there really some guy out there that we need to be looking for or did you just make this up? And they just started asking me all these questions and just grilling at me. And I just started crying. I was crying, and I was upset. I didn't understand what was going on, really.
“真的有一个我们需要搜寻的家伙，还是你编造了这一切？”他们就这样开始问我所有这些问题，对我严加拷问。我开始哭。我哭得很伤心，很绝望。我真的不明白到底发生了什么。
I just-- I'm still in shock that they didn't believe me. I was mad, too. I did pound my hand on the table and stuff like that. And the only way they would leave me alone is if I wrote a statement saying that it didn't happen.
我只是——他们不相信我，我至今仍感到震惊。我也很生气。我确实用手捶了桌子之类的。他们离开我的唯一条件就是我写一份声明，承认那件事没发生过。
So she did. She first wrote, quote, "I dreamed someone broke in and raped me." The detectives then insisted that she rewrite it, and not write that she had dreamed it but that she had lied.
所以她照做了。她起初写道，引用：“我梦见有人闯入并强奸了我。”侦探们随后坚持要求她重写，不要写她是梦到的，而要写她是撒谎了。
There are lots of reasons a victim of sex abuse might consciously choose to say something different from what happened-- shame, fear of retribution. But Marie says that isn't what was happening with her. She started having moments where she actually couldn't tell if she'd been raped.
性虐待受害者有许多理由会有意识地选择说出与事实不符的事情——羞耻、害怕报复。但玛丽说，她当时的情况并非如此。她开始出现一些时刻，自己真的无法分辨是否被强奸过。
Like, I was trying to be really honest about everything. And possibly maybe I had dreamt that stuff that first day, maybe I had dreamt it up and that it maybe didn't happen and stuff like that. And so those doubts were coming out when I was talking to them. And they just started disbelieving me even more.
比如，我当时正努力对每一件事都诚实。可能在第一天，我也许真的做梦了那些事，也许我是幻想出来的，可能那并没有发生等等。所以当我和他们说话时，那些怀疑就冒出来了。而他们就开始更加不相信我。
And then all of a sudden, I just started thinking-- I was like, did this really just happen to me, this whole thing? In my mind, I was second-guessing somebody coming into my house and doing all this stuff, you know? Is it possible that I just imagined that? Because why would something like that happen to me?
然后突然间，我开始想——我在想，这一切真的发生在我身上吗？在脑海里，我开始怀疑有人闯进我家做所有这些事，你知道？我有可能只是想象出来的吗？因为为什么那种事会发生在我身上？
I ran how Marie describes this-- not being sure herself that the assault happened-- by an expert on sex assault trauma and how it affects the brain. She said that this kind of cognitive separation, she called it, while not common, does happen, that it's directly related to the sheer shock an assault has on a person-- like, for example, being awoken by a stranger with a knife-- and that people who have been sexually abused before, like Marie, are at a much higher risk for this happening. Add foster care to that and the risk is greater.
我向一位研究性侵创伤及其对大脑影响的专家询问了玛丽如何描述这一点——即她自己也不确定袭击是否发生。她说，这种认知分离——她称之为——虽然不常见，但确实会发生，这与袭击给一个人造成的巨大冲击直接相关——比如被拿刀的陌生人惊醒——而且像玛丽这样以前受过性虐待的人，发生这种情况的风险要高得多。再加上寄养经历，风险就更大了。
At the end of that day, I was just like, fine. It all didn't happen because now I have nobody that believes me. I just wanted it to be over with. So--
那天结束时，我只是想：好吧，没发生过。因为现在没有人相信我。我只是想结束这一切。所以——
So Marie did something familiar to her. She has a way to deal with terrible things happening to her that are out of her control, what she calls flipping the switch.
所以玛丽做了一件她很熟悉的事。她有一种处理自己无法控制的可怕事情的方法，她称之为“拨动开关”。
That feeling switch inside, just, I turned it to not really caring about the emotion and thought, well, I'll just turn off that switch. And I won't have to deal with them right now. Just, I want to get out of here.
那种内心的感觉开关，我把情绪关掉，心想：好吧，我不关心这些情绪，我会把开关关掉。现在我不需要处理它们了。我只是想离开这里。
What does it look like when you kind of decide to flip the switch and stop caring so much? What is that-- how does your demeanor change when you're speaking to the police officer?
当你决定拨动开关并停止在意时，看起来是什么样的？你的态度在和警察说话时有什么变化？
Well, I'm not crying anymore and looking at them when I'm talking to them. I think I was giggling, which is something I do when I'm nervous, like I just pretended like that didn't just really happen, you know, and went in the bathroom after that and cleaned up and just kind of acted like it was fine.
嗯，我不哭也不在说话时看着他们了。我想我当时在咯咯笑，这是我紧张时会做的事，就像我假装那事没真的发生过一样，你知道，在那之后我去洗手间清洗了一下，就像没事一样表现得很好。
Both detectives noticed the switch. Rittgarn wrote, quote, "Her visual appearance and body language became remarkably different. She appeared less stressed, stopped crying, and even laughed a little." Marie wrote her final statement for the detectives at their insistence-- quote, "I made up this story," she wrote.
两位侦探都注意到了那个开关。里特加恩写道，引用：“她的视觉外观和肢体语言变得非常不同。她看起来不那么紧张，停止了哭泣，甚至还笑了一点。”玛丽在他们的坚持下写下了最后一份陈述——引用：“我编造了这个故事，”她写道。
King 5 News starts now.
King 5 新闻现在开始。
Good evening. Your--
晚上好。你的——
Police in Lynnwood now say a woman who claimed she was sexually assaulted by a stranger made up the story.
林伍德警方现在表示，一名声称被陌生人性侵的女子编造了这个故事。
This news story ran one day after Marie met with detectives and wrote those statements.
这篇新闻报道在玛丽与侦探见面并写下那些声明的第二天播出。
Earlier this week, the 18-year-old told detectives a man had broken into her apartment, raped her, and then stayed for an extended period of time. But upon further questioning, the woman admitted the assault did not happen. Detectives do not know why she made the story up.
本周早些时候，这名 18 岁的女孩告诉侦探，一名男子闯入她的公寓，强奸了她，并停留了很长时间。但经进一步询问，该女子承认袭击并未发生。侦探们不知道她为什么要编造这个故事。
At least three other stations aired similar stories. Reporters chased it.
至少有三家其他电视台播出了类似报道。记者们纷纷跟进。
Like, I had to hide. Like, I had to wear a sweatshirt over my face and sneak out of my apartment because there were just so many, just pounding on my door.
就像，我必须躲起来。就像，我必须戴上连帽衫遮住脸，偷偷溜出公寓，因为外面有那么多人，在不停地敲我的门。
The backlash was immediate. Marie got hate-filled Myspace messages, angry phone calls. One of Marie's best friends from high school put up a website attacking Marie, warning people she was a liar. It had the police reports with the statement she'd written about making up the story. It had her name and her picture.
反噬是即时的。玛丽收到了充满仇恨的 Myspace 私信，愤怒的电话。玛丽高中的一个好朋友建立了一个网站攻击玛丽，警告人们她是个骗子。上面有警察的报告，还有她写的关于编造故事的陈述。上面有她的名字和照片。
For Marie, it was too much. Police didn't believe her. Her foster moms didn't believe her. And it was all over the news. It felt like the world had turned against her. And remember, she was 18 years old, trying to figure this out.
对玛丽来说，这太沉重了。警察不相信她。她的寄养妈妈不相信她。而且这事闹得满城风雨。感觉整个世界都与她为敌。记住，她只有 18 岁，正试图弄明白这一切。
She wanted a lawyer. And she had a support system that could have helped her find one. She lived in her own apartment, but it was subsidized by a nonprofit that helped teenagers like Marie transition out of foster care. Project Ladder, it was called. They taught life skills like how to use a credit card, how to shop for groceries. They were there to give her a hand.
她想要个律师。她本有一个支持系统可以帮她找到一个。她住在自己的公寓里，但这是由一个帮助像玛丽这样过渡出寄养系统的非营利组织资助的。“梯子计划”，就是它的名字。他们教生活技能，比如如何使用信用卡，如何买菜。他们本应伸出援手。
So she asked them to help her find a lawyer. Instead, her case manager called the police, who told him there was no evidence that a rape had occurred. They did not get her a lawyer.
所以她请他们帮她找个律师。相反，她的个案经理给警察打了电话，警察告诉他没有任何证据表明发生了强奸案。他们没给她找律师。
So then they said, OK. Well, we're going to go to the police station. You're going to tell them that. You're going to tell them that it really did happen. You're going to be honest.
所以他们说：好吧。我们要去警察局。你要告诉他们真相。你要老实交代。
When they got to the station, Detective Mason, the lead detective in her case, wasn't there. He was out that day. So detective Rittgarn grabbed another cop to help out. Here's Marie.
当他们到达警局时，本案的首席侦探梅森侦探不在。他那天出去了。所以里特加恩侦探拉了另一名警察来帮忙。这是玛丽。
I told him that I wanted to recant and that it really did happen. They should be out there looking for a rapist.
我告诉他我想撤销声明，那确实发生了。他们应该出去寻找强奸犯。
Rittgarn didn't believe her. The other cop didn't know the case and was just following Rittgarn's lead. Marie says one of the detectives told her that if she kept insisting she was raped, she might have to take a polygraph test.
里特加恩不相信她。另一名警察不知道案情，只是跟着里特加恩的思路。玛丽说其中一名侦探告诉她，如果她继续坚持说自己被强奸了，可能就得接受测谎仪测试。
He told me that if I took a lie detector test and it came back that I was lying, that he was going to take me to jail himself.
他告诉我，如果我接受测谎测试，结果显示我在撒谎，他就亲自送我去监狱。
Using a polygraph on a rape victim is a mistake, a big enough one that the federal government can withhold money from states if their police departments do it. The tests are seen as a deterrent to women coming forward to report sexual assault. Plus, they're famously unreliable, especially on someone who's traumatized.
对强奸受害者使用测谎仪是个错误，大到足以让联邦政府在警方这样做时停止发放资金。这种测试被视为阻止妇女报案的威慑手段。此外，它们以不可靠著称，尤其是在受创伤的人身上。
Rittgarn's report says it was actually Marie who brought up the polygraph, not the cops. But what's not in dispute is that once the idea of a polygraph came up, Detective Rittgarn used it to threaten Marie. It's a tactic police use when they're interrogating someone they suspect in a crime. Detective Rittgarn told Marie that if she failed the polygraph, he'd recommend she lose her housing assistance and get jail time.
里特加恩的报告说，其实是玛丽先提到了测谎仪，而不是警察。但不可争辩的是，一旦测谎仪的概念被提出，里特加恩侦探就用它来威胁玛丽。这是警察在审讯犯罪嫌疑人时使用的策略。里特加恩侦探告诉玛丽，如果她测谎未通过，他将建议取消她的住房援助，并让她入狱。
Well, that scared me, so I didn't want to do that. And so I was like, OK, never mind. It really didn't happen. I didn't want to go to jail.
嗯，那吓到我了，所以我不想那样做。所以我说：好的，算了。这确实没发生。我不想去坐牢。
That night, the Project Ladder managers called a meeting.
那天晚上，“梯子计划”的经理们召开了一次会议。
It was just an emergency meeting. And they didn't tell anybody why until everybody got there.
那只是一个紧急会议。直到每个人都到齐之前，他们没告诉任何人原因。
This is Elisabeth, another former foster kid in the Project Ladder program. She was there at the meeting, along with nine or so others, mostly girls, and the program managers, sitting in chairs in a circle. Marie remembers it as the lowest moment of this whole ordeal, the one time she thought about suicide. Again, here's Elisabeth.
这是伊丽莎白，也是“梯子计划”的另一位前寄养孩子。她参加了会议，和大约九个其他人一起，主要是女孩，还有项目经理，坐在椅子上围成一个圆圈。玛丽回忆起这是整个苦难中最低谷的时刻，她唯一一次想过自杀。再次说明，这是伊丽莎白。
Marie stood up. And she was crying. And she said that she had lied about what had happened.
玛丽站了起来。她在哭。她说她撒谎了，并没有那回事。
To the group?
对集体吗？
To the group. Yeah, everybody. I mean, it just felt like she was just forced to say that and that it was-- I mean, there was nothing in her words or actions that she meant. I mean, it was more of defeat is what it sounded like, just kind of giving up on trying to prove herself. She just seemed devastated and lost.
对集体。是的，所有人。我的意思是，感觉她是被迫这么说的，而且这——我的意思是，从她的言语和行动中，完全看不出她是真心的。我的意思是，那听起来更像是失败，只是放弃了试图证明自己。她看起来既崩溃又迷茫。
It actually sounds really confusing from your perspective. Were you wondering, why is she being made to say this?
从你的角度听起来真的很令人困惑。你当时在想，为什么逼她说这些？
I mean, I really was because I didn't know her. And at first, I didn't really know what to believe. You know, it's just kind of an odd thing to say, "oh, well I made it up." I think maybe my own personal experiences kind of came through when she said that. And I kind of--
我的意思是，我真的很困惑，因为我不认识她。起初，我不知道该信什么。你知道，说“哦，好吧，是我编的”是件很奇怪的事情。我想也许我自己的个人经历在她说出那话时有所共鸣。我当时就——
What kind of personal experiences?
什么样的个人经历？
I've-- I was sexually assaulted. And so, I mean, being afraid of saying anything, and then not having anybody to believe you, and then just kind of trying to forget about it, I guess, trying to--
我曾——我也曾遭到性侵。所以，害怕说出任何事情，没有人相信你，然后试图忘记它，我想，试图——
Trying to move on or something.
试图继续前进什么的。
Move on. Yeah.
继续前进。是的。
Elisabeth felt for Marie. She says there were a couple others who looked like they did, too. But they were in the minority. Mainly, Marie says, people were angry.
伊丽莎白同情玛丽。她说还有几个看起来也同情她。但她们是少数。玛丽说，主要是，人们很愤怒。
They were pretty mad about it. One of the girls, she was calling me and making threats at me, thought I was a liar and basically mentally ill for making up something like that.
她们当时非常生气。其中一个女孩打电话威胁我，认为我是骗子，基本上还因为编造那种事而被认为有精神病。
I spoke to one of the meeting's angry girls. She didn't want to be interviewed, but she told me she thought Marie had lied, and it did make her mad. But she also said-- and Elisabeth told me this, too-- there was something so obvious and transparent about the premise of the meeting. It was a message to everyone-- we're making her tell you this so none of you think about doing it. If you do, you'll lose your housing.
我采访了其中一个愤怒的女孩。她不想接受采访，但她告诉我她认为玛丽撒谎了，这确实让她很生气。但她也说——伊丽莎白也告诉了我这一点——会议的前提有一些非常明显和透明的东西。这是传达给所有人的信息——我们逼她告诉你们这些，所以你们谁也别想那么做。如果你们做了，就会失去住房。
Elisabeth described the woman running the meeting as fuming. We reached out to the Project Ladder managers, but they never replied. Elisabeth stuck by Marie, and one other friend. Friend-wise, that was about it. Elisabeth says Marie was avoided like--
伊丽莎白形容主持会议的女人气得冒烟。我们联系了“梯子计划”的经理，但他们从未回复。伊丽莎白和另外一个朋友站在玛丽这一边。在朋友层面，也就仅此而已了。伊丽莎白说玛丽像——
The plague. Yeah. I mean, that's exactly how it was. People treated her like she was-- they couldn't get far enough away from her. And people, they were very cruel to her. Of course, the phone calls and the nasty stuff on social media. I mean, I even believe, like, when we'd walk through the parking lot or we'd go somewhere, somebody would say something, calling her a whore, and die, and just a lot of really horrible stuff.
像瘟疫一样被避开。是的。我的意思是，事实就是那样。人们对待她就像她是——他们恨不得离她越远越好。而且人们对她非常残忍。当然，还有那些社交媒体上的电话和恶毒的东西。我的意思是，我甚至记得当我们走过停车场或去某个地方时，有人会说些什么，叫她妓女，叫她去死，还有很多非常可怕的事情。
I mean, I even remember reading one of the comments on the-- it was on the internet, but I don't remember what exactly page it was or anything. "But this bitch is the reason that nobody believes when women say they get raped."
我的意思是，我甚至记得在互联网上看过一条评论——但我不记得确切是什么网页或什么的了——“但这婊子就是导致没人相信女人被强奸的原因。”
Wow.
哇。
Yeah. I mean, there was a lot of that.
是的。我的意思是，那种话很多。
Even Shannon, who meant the world to Marie. She told Marie that she couldn't spend the night at her house anymore because her husband worried she might make up a story about him. And if all that weren't enough, about a week later, Marie received a summons in the mail. Police were charging her with false reporting.
即使是香农，那个对玛丽意义重大的人。她告诉玛丽她不能再在她家过夜了，因为她丈夫担心她可能会编造关于他的故事。如果这一切还不够，大约一周后，玛丽在邮件里收到了传票。警方指控她报假案。
The false reporting charge meant that Marie's rape case would be officially closed. The physical evidence police had gathered at the scene was destroyed except for a single fingerprint card that was left behind. Everything else-- the rape kit, the bedding, the DNA swabs-- they were never even tested in a crime lab, never analyzed. Further evidence that could have been gathered never was.
报假案的指控意味着玛丽的强奸案将正式关闭。警方在现场收集的物证除了留下一张指纹卡外，全部被销毁。其他所有东西——强奸取证包、寝具、DNA拭子——甚至从未在犯罪实验室进行测试，从未进行过分析。本可以收集到的进一步证据也从未被收集。
Two months after Marie was charged with false reporting, Shannon was sitting at home, watching the local news with her husband, when on came a story about a woman in Kirkland, another Seattle suburb, who reported being raped by a stranger who broke in, threatened her with a knife, used shoelaces to tie her up, and who took pictures and threatened to post them on the internet.
玛丽被起诉报假案两个月后，香农坐在家里和丈夫看地方新闻，这时播出了一个故事，关于柯克兰——另一个西雅图郊区——的一名女子。她报案称被一个闯入的陌生人强奸，他威胁她，用鞋带绑住她，并拍照威胁要发布到网上。
Right away, I thought, I'm wrong. It actually happened. She was raped because this is too similar. So I immediately went in and called the Kirkland Police Department and asked to speak to the lead detective on the rape case. And I explained the whole situation about what had happened to Marie and that the Lynnwood police didn't believe her. But it was just too similar, and it had just happened.
我立刻就想：我错了。这是真的发生了。她被强奸了，因为这太相似了。所以我立刻打电话给柯克兰警察局，要求与该强奸案的首席侦探通话。我解释了关于玛丽发生的一切，以及林伍德警察不相信她。但太相似了，而且就在刚才发生了。
So I asked them to call the Lynnwood police. Then he got back to me and said he did talk to them, but they had determined that she had made the whole thing up, and the case was closed. And that was the end. And it was over.
所以我让他们给林伍德警方打电话。然后他回电说他确实和他们谈过了，但他们认定她编造了整个故事，案件已结。就这样。结束了。
I talked to the lead detective that Shannon spoke to and to another Kirkland detective on this case. Both remember talking to the Lynnwood PD. But when they learned the Lynnwood police didn't believe their victim, that was it. They didn't look any further. One detective said she figured the Lynnwood police knew their case best. She trusted their judgment.
我采访了香农联系的那位首席侦探以及柯克兰在该案上的另一位侦探。他们都记得与林伍德警方的通话。但当他们得知林伍德警察不相信受害者时，也就那样了。他们没有深入调查。一位侦探说，她认为林伍德警察最了解他们的案子。她信任他们的判断。
Even so, one thing they both told me they were surprised by was that the Lynnwood police had gone so far as to charge Marie with false reporting. One detective remembers hanging up the phone thinking, OK. Hope that works out for you guys.
即便如此，有一件事他们都告诉我令他们惊讶的是，林伍德警察竟然走得那么远，起诉玛丽报假案。一位侦探记得挂断电话时想：好吧。希望这对你们有效。
Shannon grew up in a police family. She usually figured police knew best. Not this time.
香农是在警察家庭长大的。她通常认为警察最懂。这次不是。
I was upset. I thought there should have been more investigation, that it was just too similar.
我很心烦。我认为应该进行更多的调查，这太相似了。
Shannon thought something had to be done. She thought Marie should get in touch with the Kirkland police herself. She told Marie--
香农认为必须要做点什么。她认为玛丽应该亲自联系柯克兰警察。她告诉玛丽——
If it did happen, then here's a second chance to go talk to the police about what happened to you because this just happened to another woman. But she wouldn't go. And so that, then, made me doubt again. Why wouldn't she want to get involved to try and prove that she was innocent?
如果真的发生了，那现在是第二次机会去和警察谈谈发生了什么，因为这个事刚刚发生在另一个女人身上。但她不肯去。而那，又让我再次怀疑。为什么她不想参与进来试图证明她自己是清白的呢？
Marie didn't want to talk to anybody else about the rape, especially not police again. The very thought terrified her. What she wanted, more than anything, was to put this behind her. In March of 2009, seven months after she was raped, Marie went to court to accept a plea deal on her false reporting charge. Under the deal, to get the charge dropped, she would need to meet certain conditions for a year. She'd go on supervised probation, pay $500 in court costs, and she'd get mental health counseling, not for being raped but for lying about it.
玛丽不想再和任何人谈论强奸的事，特别是再也不想和警察谈。仅仅是想到这一点就让她感到恐惧。她最想要的，就是把这一切抛在脑后。2009 年 3 月，即她被强奸七个月后，玛丽出庭接受了报假案的认罪协议。根据该协议，为撤销指控，她需要满足为期一年的特定条件。她将接受监督缓刑，支付 500 美元诉讼费，并接受心理健康咨询，不是为了被强奸，而是为了撒谎。
Coming up-- today's program is about two police investigations of the same crime. The second investigation, where the police do a stunningly great job, in a minute, when our program continues.
接下来——今天的节目是关于两起同一犯罪的警方调查。第二起调查，警方做得令人惊叹，一分钟后节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Anatomy of Doubt." We have the story of two criminal investigations. One goes great, one goes about as badly as it possibly could. We now turn to the successful investigation. It happens in a suburb of Denver called Golden, Colorado. The lead detectives in this second case were very experienced, versus the lead detective in the first case, who only had done one or two other rape cases.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“怀疑的解剖”。我们有两起刑事调查的故事。一个结果很好，一个糟糕透顶。我们现在转向那个成功的调查。它发生在丹佛郊区叫戈尔登的地方，科罗拉多州。第二起案件的首席侦探经验非常丰富，与第一起案件只办过一两次强奸案的首席侦探形成对比。
This was stated earlier, but I'll just repeat it here-- the content of today's program probably isn't right for little kids. Here are Ken Armstrong and Robyn Semien.
之前提到了，但我会在这里重申——今天节目的内容可能不适合小孩子。这是肯·阿姆斯特朗和罗宾·塞米恩。
Two years later-- January, 2011-- Detective Stacy Galbraith got a case. A grad student, mid-20s, had been sexually assaulted in her home, raped at gunpoint. To cover his tracks, her attacker took her sheets with him and made her shower to wash off any DNA. And when she went to interview the victim, Detective Galbraith says, the victim remembered an unusual number of details about the guy, way more than any other rape victim she'd talked to before. The victim had basically chatted him up, and he told her things, like he spoke four different languages.
两年后——2011 年 1 月——斯泰西·加尔布雷思侦探接手了一个案子。一名研究生， 20 多岁，在家里遭到了性侵，在枪口下被强奸。为了掩盖行踪，袭击者带走了她的床单，并让她冲澡洗掉 DNA。当她去采访受害者时，加尔布雷思侦探说，受害者记得关于那个人的不同寻常数量的细节，比她之前采访过的任何强奸受害者都多。受害者基本上和他聊了起来，他告诉了她一些事情，比如他会说四种不同的语言。
And she was able to kind of rattle off a few of those. He traveled a lot. He talked about math. He told her that he has no problem with finding girlfriends or having girlfriends. But he just doesn't like the consensual aspect of the girlfriend relationship.
而且她能随口说出其中的几个。他经常旅行。他谈论数学。他告诉她，他找女朋友或有女朋友没问题。但他只是不喜欢女朋友关系中那种“双方同意”的方面。
The victim had a good guess of his height and weight and knew that he had a distinct mark on his leg-- a birthmark, she told Detective Galbraith, the size and shape of an egg. He'd had a camera with him, and she remembered the color and brand of the camera.
受害者对他的身高和体重有很好的猜测，并知道他腿上有明显的标记——一个胎记，她告诉加尔布雷思侦探，鸡蛋的大小和形状。他带着相机，她记得相机的颜色和品牌。
She described it as a pink Sony.
她形容它是粉红色的索尼。
Detective Galbraith noted that the victim wasn't crying. She didn't seem upset.
加尔布雷思侦探注意到受害者没有哭。她看起来并不沮丧。
She was very kind of stoic in her report of this incident. I mean, you could even say she had more of a flat affect, actually.
她在讲述这起事件时表现得非常冷静。我的意思是，你甚至可以说她表现出更多的是一种情感淡漠，事实上。
Was there anything unusual about that?
那有什么不寻常的吗？
Very unusual. Typically, I mean, I encounter somebody, say, in the hospital or on a scene that's crying, upset, much more, I would say, visibly traumatized than this victim was. She talked about this guy and the horrible-- my word is horrible-- things that he did to her for a number of hours. And in relation to other victims, they probably would have said horrible. They would have been revealing the horrible side of the things that they'd done.
非常不寻常。通常，我的意思是，我在医院或现场遇到的人在哭泣、沮丧，比这位受害者在情感上更明显地受到了创伤。她谈论这个家伙和他对她做的那些可怕的事——我用“可怕”这个词——长达几个小时。相对于其他受害者，她们可能会说“可怕”。她们会揭露她们经历过的可怕的一面。
She-- I remember we were walking outside for some reason. I don't know why we were outside. And she was talking about that he was a gentleman, calm, mild mannered. And I just remember just thinking, how can anyone, after this happened, call this person a gentleman?
我记得我们当时因为某种原因走在外面。我不知道为什么我们在外面。她谈到他是一个绅士，冷静，温和。我只记得当时就在想，在发生这种事之后，怎么会有人称这个人是绅士呢？
Detective Galbraith at this point had worked dozens of rape cases, maybe 50. She admitted she didn't totally get her victim but that it didn't get in the way of her investigating the crime. Detective Galbraith talked to her husband about the case that night. And her husband, a police officer in another town, remembered a case just like it in his department in Westminster.
加尔布雷思侦探当时已经办过几十起强奸案，也许 50 起。她承认她并不完全理解她的受害者，但这并没有阻碍她调查犯罪。加尔布雷思侦探那天晚上和她丈夫谈到了这个案子。她丈夫是另一个城镇的警察，想起他所在部门威斯敏斯特也有一个一模一样的案子。
So Detective Galbraith contacted Westminster PD the next morning to look at their case file-- details almost identical. The lead detective on that case, Edna Hendershot, says there was one striking connection.
所以加尔布雷思侦探第二天早上联系了威斯敏斯特警局查阅他们的案卷——细节几乎完全一致。该案的首席侦探埃德娜·亨德肖特说，有一个惊人的联系。
In my assault, my victim was the victim of a theft, also, of a pink Sony Cyber-shot camera that was stolen from her. And Stacy knew that her victim was photographed using a pink Sony Cyber-shot camera.
在我的袭击案中，我的受害者也遭到盗窃，一部粉红色的索尼 Cyber-shot 相机被偷了。而斯泰西知道她的受害者是在被拍下时用的就是粉红色的索尼 Cyber-shot 相机。
Detective Hendershot also said there was a third rape in another town nearby, which made them think there could be a serial offender. The three departments did something that doesn't always happen with different police departments-- they started meeting, working together.
亨德肖特侦探还说，附近另一个城镇发生了第三起强奸案，这让他们认为可能存在连环犯罪者。这三个部门做了些不同警察部门之间不常做的事情——他们开始开会，共同合作。
Each department had come up with some kind of trace DNA associated with their victims, not the definitive kind that can positively ID a suspect, but not nothing, either. The samples were tested for similarities, and the results showed that they were connected paternally, meaning the three DNA samples had to be the same guy or men in the same family.
每个部门都找出了与受害者相关的某种痕迹 DNA，不是那种能确凿锁定嫌疑人的 DNA，但也不是一无所获。样本进行了相似性测试，结果显示它们在父系上有联系，意味着这三个 DNA 样本必须是同一个人或者是同一家族的男性。
About five weeks into Detective Stacy Galbraith's investigation, there's a big meeting. Federal, state, and local investigators are there, and a fourth local department, too. And in that meeting, someone new to the group, a female crime analyst, stands up. She'd done a search for suspicious vehicles in the vicinity of an attempted rape. Detective Hendershot says at the very end of the meeting--
在斯泰西·加尔布雷思侦探的调查进入大约第五周时，召开了一个大型会议。联邦、州和地方调查员都在场，还有第四个地方部门也在。在会议上，一个新人，一名女性犯罪分析师站了起来。她在一次未遂强奸案附近搜寻过可疑车辆。亨德肖特侦探说在会议最后——
She happens to mention, just so the group knows, I came across this Mazda truck that was near this crime scene, just so the group knows. Well, when Stacy hears that, Stacy is like, wait a second. What did you say?
她碰巧提到，让大家知道，我在这个犯罪现场附近碰到过一辆马自达皮卡，只是让大家知道。嗯，当斯泰西听到这个时，斯泰西就像：等等。你说什么？
I tell them-- I said, that's a truck on our surveillance video that wasn't very relevant until right now. It just all came together, one second. It was just a [SNAPS].
我告诉他们——我说，那是我们在监控视频中看到的一辆皮卡，直到刚才还没那么相关。就在这一秒，一切都串起来了。就像是 [响指]。
Detective Stacy Galbraith had only seen the truck on a fuzzy surveillance video. But this analyst had the make, model, and license plate. It was registered to a guy named Marc O'Leary. Detective Hendershot, always reluctant to get too ahead of herself, remembers thinking--
斯泰西·加尔布雷思侦探只在模糊的监控视频中见过那辆皮卡。但这位分析师有品牌、型号和车牌。车主登记在一个叫马克·奥利里的人名下。亨德肖特侦探，总是很谨慎，不愿操之过急，记得当时想——
Wow, that's a pretty big piece of evidence, potentially.
哇，那是一个相当大的证据，潜在地。
What they needed now was a DNA sample from Marc O'Leary to see if it tied him to the crimes. So FBI agents stake out Marc's house. The plan was to wait for him to leave, then they'd split up, have a few agents follow him while others put up surveillance cameras outside his house while he was gone. When Marc leaves his house, agents trail him. But what they didn't know is that Marc O'Leary had a brother who lived with him in the same house.
他们现在需要马克·奥利里的 DNA 样本来看看是否能把他和犯罪联系起来。所以联邦调查局特工在马克的家外蹲点。计划是等他离开，然后他们分开，派几个特工跟踪他，而其他人趁他离开时在他的房子外安装监控摄像头。当马克离开家时，特工跟踪他。但他们不知道的是，马克·奥利里有一个兄弟和他住在同一栋房子里。
So the guy they were following wasn't Marc at all but his slightly younger, similar-looking brother. So when other agents go to the apartment and knock on the door expecting it to be empty, they're shocked when Marc answers. The agents think quickly, say they're informing people in the neighborhood about a burglar. They even have a flyer with a phony suspect photo to show him. The conversation ends. Marc goes inside.
所以他们跟踪的人根本不是马克，而是他稍微年轻、长相相似的兄弟。所以当其他特工去公寓敲门期待它是空的时，马克应门让他们大吃一惊。特工们反应很快，说是在告知邻居关于盗贼的事情。他们甚至有一张带有虚假嫌疑人照片的传单展示给他看。谈话结束。马克进屋了。
Meanwhile, Marc's brother  is eating in a diner. And when he's done, agents swoop in to get DNA off his glass, which brings them closer to their answer but still not all the way there because while DNA from the brother does link the brothers' family line to the crimes, it does not tell them which brother committed them. Here's Detective Galbraith.
与此同时，马克的兄弟正在餐馆吃饭。当他吃完后，特工们突然冲上去从他的玻璃杯上取到了 DNA，这让他们离答案更近了一步，但还没完全到位，因为虽然兄弟的 DNA 确实把兄弟俩的家族线与罪行联系起来，但并没有告诉他们是哪个兄弟干的。这是加尔布雷思侦探。
So at this point, we're like, crap. It could be either one, really. We need to see the leg of both of them--
所以在这个时候，我们在想，糟了。确实可能是其中任何一个。我们需要看看他们两个的腿——
For a birthmark. They need to see that birthmark.
寻找胎记。他们需要看到那个胎记。
Two days later, Detective Galbraith and her team go to Marc's house.
两天后，加尔布雷思侦探和她的团队去了马克家。
And Marc comes to the door. And we have weapons out. And I tell him that we have a search warrant for the house. And I pat him down to make sure he doesn't have any weapons. He's got real baggy clothes on when he comes out. And so when I'm patting him down, I lifted up both pant legs, and I saw the mark.
马克来开门。我们拿出了武器。我告诉他我们有搜查房子的搜查令。我对他进行搜身确保他没有武器。他出来时穿着非常宽松的衣服。所以当我搜身时，我掀起了他的两条裤腿，我看到了那个标记。
What'd you think when you saw the mark?
当你看到标记时你是怎么想的？
He's the guy. He needed to be in handcuffs. He was very surprised. He went almost blue.
他是那个家伙。他需要戴上手铐。他非常惊讶。他的脸几乎都发青了。
She arrested him. Galbraith says it's the most satisfying case she ever worked on.
她逮捕了他。加尔布雷思说这是她经手过的最令人满意的案子。
When the police searched the house, they found shoelaces and other bindings, lock-picking tools, a gun, the pink Sony camera, and, stowed away in the back of an amplifier, underwear he'd collected from his victims. Also, computers, hard drives, thumb drives, media cards, which produced hundreds of images, photos of victims.
当警察搜查房子时，他们发现了鞋带和其他捆绑工具、开锁工具、一把枪、粉红色的索尼相机，还有，藏在功放机后部，他从受害者那里收集来的内衣。还有电脑、硬盘、U 盘、存储卡，产生了数百张图像、受害者的照片。
Detective Galbraith went through them all. There are pictures of women from the towns in Colorado and--
加尔布雷思侦探看完了所有这些。有来自科罗拉多州各城镇的女人的照片，还有——
A picture of another woman with a Washington driver's license on her chest that was gagged and bound.
一张另一个女人胸前放着华盛顿州驾驶证的照片，她被塞住嘴并捆绑着。
It was Marie.
那是玛丽。
I'm thinking, thank God. I don't have just an unknown victim here that I may never know who she is. I know who this is. Well, I mean, I'm thinking he probably did that as a form of intimidation to her-- I know who you are. I'll have your name and your address. But it helped us, actually.
我在想，谢天谢地。我这里不仅仅有一个我可能永远不知道是谁的不知名受害者。我知道这是谁。嗯，我的意思是，我在想他可能把那个作为恐吓她的一种方式——我知道你是谁。我知道你的名字和地址。但这实际上帮助了我们。
Detective Galbraith contacted the Lynnwood PD hoping to wrap up their case. She had the case file faxed to her. But what she remembers is the cover page of that fax, which read "false reporting."
加尔布雷思侦探联系了林伍德警局，希望能结束他们的案子。她让人传真了案卷。但她记得那份传真封面写着“报假案”。
My heart sunk, and I was shocked. I was like, oh, cussword, because I knew that was wrong.
我的心沉了下去，我很震惊。我心想，哦，该死，因为我知道那是错的。
After police filed their false reporting charge against Marie, Marc O'Leary went on to rape at least four other women-- the three women in Colorado plus the woman he raped in the Seattle suburb near Marie. He pleaded guilty to five rapes and over 20 other felonies. He was sentenced to over 300 years in prison.
在警察对玛丽提起报假案指控后，马克·奥利里又强奸了至少四名女性——科罗拉多州的三名女性加上他在西雅图郊区玛丽附近强奸的那名女子。他承认了五起强奸案和其他 20 多项重罪。他被判处 300 多年监禁。
In a post-sentencing interview with police, he admitted stalking victims over time, sometimes breaking and entering in the weeks before an attack to plan and make sure a woman was living by herself and didn't have a dog. He also said he knew police departments weren't great at talking to one another. So he planned his attacks, deliberately, in different cities.
在判刑后的采访中，他承认长期跟踪受害者，有时在袭击前几周闯入，策划并确保女人独自居住而且没有狗。他还说他知道警察部门不善于相互交流。所以他蓄意在不同的城市策划攻击。
In March, 2011, two years after Marie took a plea deal for filing a false police report, she got a visit from the head of the Lynnwood PD's criminal investigations division, Commander Steve Rider.
2011 年 3 月，即玛丽因报假案达成认罪协议两年后，她收到了林伍德警局刑事调查部门主管史蒂夫·莱德指挥官的到访。
We were invited in, told Marie who we were.
我们获准进入，告诉玛丽我们是谁。
They asked if I had somewhere quiet they could talk to me.
他们问我是否有安静的地方可以谈话。
And I just remember not knowing what I'm going to say. As much as I thought about this moment, I don't know how to say this. I don't even remember the words I used.
我只记得不知道该说些什么。尽管我想到过这一刻，但我不知道该怎么说。我甚至不记得我用了什么词。
They said they found the guy. They have this little piece of evidence. They said that they had found a picture. And the picture they found was of my ID. And I just broke down. They paid me back the $500 and told me that they were going to get my record expunged.
他们说他们找到了那个人。他们有这件小证据。他们说他们发现了一张照片。他们发现的照片是我的身份证。我崩溃了。他们退还了那 500 美元，并告诉他们会把我的记录注销。
She just looked stunned, and we were stunned. And it was hard.
她看起来很震惊，我们也震惊。那很艰难。
I didn't really say much after that. I just-- I didn't really have much to say after they told me that. They were just like, we're sorry. We're deeply sorry, you know, about what had happened to you. But it didn't mean much to me at all.
那之后我没说什么。我只是——在他们告诉我之后，我真的没太多话可说。他们只是说：我们很抱歉。我们深感抱歉，关于发生在你身上的事。但那对我来说根本没有任何意义。
Sergeant Jeffrey Mason, the lead detective in the case, hadn't thought about Marie's case in years. He was sure she'd lied, so he just moved on. And then he got a phone call telling him that a serial rapist had been arrested in Colorado, that Marie had been raped by this man, that Marie had been telling the truth.
杰弗里·梅森警官，案子的首席侦探，已经好几年没想过玛丽的案子了。他确信她撒谎了，所以就翻篇了。然后他接到电话，得知一名连环强奸犯在科罗拉多州被捕，玛丽是被这个人强奸的，玛丽一直说的是实话。
Yeah, I was-- I was driving to my office. It's one of those times that you're not going to forget. It was so shocking that this has been the one thing where I seriously step back and question if I should continue doing what I'm doing.
是的，我当时——我正开车去办公室。这是你永远不会忘记的时刻之一。这件事太令人震惊了，以至于我不得不认真退后一步，质疑我是否应该继续做我现在所做的事情。
Marie requested a personal apology from Mason, and she got one in the same police station where two and a half years before she had been interrogated as a criminal suspect instead of treated as a rape victim. Marie says he seemed sincere and ashamed. He rubbed his head. He looked like a lost little puppy, is how she puts it.
玛丽要求梅森亲自道歉，她就在同一间警察局里得到了道歉——两年半前，她就是在那里被审讯为犯罪嫌疑人，而不是被视为强奸受害者。玛丽说他看起来很诚恳，很惭愧。他揉着头。用她的话说，他看起来像只丢失的小狗。
And then there were Shannon and Peggy, the two adults who mattered the most to Marie as a teenager. They are both still in her life today. This is Shannon.
然后是香农和佩吉，那两个作为青少年时期对玛丽最重要的成年人。她们今天仍在她的生活中。这是香农。
It was very complicated. Knowing they'd caught him, at the same moment knowing that it had actually happened, that she was actually raped. And nobody believed her, especially the people in her life that had been supporting her and had been taking care of her and trying to mentor her and help her. And we didn't believe her.
这非常复杂。得知他们抓到了他，同时意识到那确实发生了，她是真的被强奸了。而且没人相信她，尤其是她生命中那些一直在支持她、照顾她、试图指导她和帮助她的人。我们不相信她。
And so I told her that I didn't want to say I was sorry over the phone, that I wanted to do it in person. So she came up. And we went for a walk. And I just took her shoulders, and I said, I want to look in your eyes and tell you from the bottom of my heart, I am so sorry I doubted you and I didn't believe you and we didn't support you. And she said that was OK, gave me a big hug. And I was just so shocked that she would be willing to forgive me for that because it was such a huge thing. And it went on for so long.
所以我告诉她，我不想在电话里道歉，我想亲自道歉。所以她来了。我们去散步。我握住她的肩膀，我说：“我想看着你的眼睛，从我心底深处告诉你，我很抱歉怀疑你，我不相信你，我们没支持你。”她说那没关系，给了我一个大大的拥抱。我非常震惊她愿意原谅我，因为那是一件大事。而且持续了那么久。
The worst, horrible part of this whole thing for me is that I did talk to the police. And I regret that now.
对我来说，这一切中最糟糕、最可怕的部分是我确实和警察谈了。我现在对此感到后悔。
Of course, this is Peggy. Shannon and Peggy have thought a lot about what happened and their role in it. They doubted Marie because of something so normal and human. They trusted their intuition about someone they knew really well. It's hard not to do that. They had a gut feeling that was wrong but felt utterly true.
当然，这是佩吉。香农和佩吉想了很多关于发生了什么以及她们在其中的角色。她们怀疑玛丽是因为一些非常正常和人性化的原因。她们信任自己对某个非常了解的人的直觉。不那样做很难。她们有一种直觉是错的，但感觉完全真实。
But trauma works in complicated ways. You can't tell if someone was raped by how they're acting. They can be subdued and detached, but they can also be hyper and laughing. They can go back and forth. Sometimes, they tell no one what happened. Sometimes, they tell a lot of people. Sometimes, they're not sure if the assault actually happened.
但创伤以复杂的方式运作。你无法通过一个人的表现来判断她是否被强奸。她们可以表现得拘谨和超脱，但也可以亢奋和大笑。她们可以反复无常。有时，她们什么都不告诉别人。有时，她们告诉很多人。有时，她们不确定袭击是否真的发生过。
At this point, Peggy knows that. But even now, she can't shake the feeling she had that led her to call police in the first place.
到了这一点，佩吉知道了。但即使现在，她也无法摆脱最初促使她给警察打电话的那种感觉。
Obviously, wish I hadn't. But on the other hand, there was all these other things, you know? I mean, the police and the way that Marie was acting. I mean, she on some level needs to take responsibility for that, too. I'm sorry, but that's true. And--
显然，我希望我没打。但另一方面，还有所有这些其他的事情，你知道？我的意思是，警察和玛丽表现的方式。我的意思是，在某种程度上，她也需要为此承担责任。我很抱歉，但这确实是真的。而且——
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
She needs to realize at some point, and I think she does now, that-- OK, I hate to say this. But you know, I mean-- OK, now this is going to sound really bad, like I'm blaming the victim. But some of the way that she was acting was part of the reason why it had the outcome that it did. And I am not the only person that didn't believe her.
她需要在某个时候意识到，我想她现在意识到了——好吧，我讨厌这么说。但是你知道，我的意思是——好吧，这听起来会很糟糕，就像我在责怪受害者。但她表现出的某些方式是导致它产生那种结果的原因之一。而且我不是唯一一个不相信她的人。
But also, it sounds like everyone who was doubting her didn't have much information about the way that rape trauma can function. And so is this about the way that she acted?
但这也听起来，所有怀疑她的人都没有关于性侵创伤如何运作的信息。所以这是关于她表现的方式吗？
Well, it shouldn't be about the way that she acted. But, unfortunately, the reality is that that did influence-- and it sounds really harsh for me to say that. It's not her fault because I think it's totally a product of what she went through. But on the other hand-- oh, God. I don't know.
嗯，不应该关乎她表现的方式。但遗憾的是，事实是那确实产生了影响——我这样说听起来很刺耳。这不是她的错，因为我认为这完全是她所经历的产物。但另一方面——哦，天哪。我不知道。
What she does know is that she never expected her feelings to derail an entire police investigation. She's mad police let that happen.
她知道的是，她从没预料到她的感受会脱轨整个警察调查。她对警察让这种情况发生感到愤怒。
Detective Mason takes full responsibility for what happened. Commander Rider, Mason's boss, head of the criminal investigations division, calls Marie's case, quote, "a major failing," one his department thinks of often. He says the detectives should never have given Peggy's call the weight they did.
梅森侦探为所发生的一切承担全部责任。莱德指挥官，梅森的上司，刑事调查部门主管，称玛丽的案子引用：“是一个重大的失败”，这是他部门经常想到的。他说侦探们根本不应该赋予佩吉的那通电话那么大的权重。
The Lynnwood Police Department's own internal review of the case said the same. The report said the call, quote, "caused the detectives to change their focus towards investigating the victim for false reporting." No one was disciplined in the case. Marie sued Lynnwood and its police officers and wound up settling for $150,000. She also sued the Project Ladder managers and the nonprofit that oversaw Project Ladder, Cocoon House.
林伍德警察局内部对该案的审查也说了同样的话。报告称那通电话引用：“导致侦探们将焦点转移到调查受害者报假案上。”没有人因为该案受到纪律处分。玛丽起诉了林伍德及其警官，最终以 15 万美元达成和解。她还起诉了“梯子计划”的经理和监督“梯子计划”的非营利组织 Cocoon House。
Cocoon House issued a statement at the time saying, quote, "Our hearts go out to Marie and her family. We strongly believe that Cocoon House and its employees acted appropriately on behalf of the client," the client meaning Marie. Cocoon House settled the lawsuit.
Cocoon House 当时发表声明称引用：“我们的心与玛丽及其家人同在。我们坚信 Cocoon House 及其员工代表客户采取了恰当行动，”客户指的就是玛丽。Cocoon House 和解了诉讼。
Marie says her conclusion and her advice to any woman who wants to report a sexual assault-- bring proof.
玛丽说她的结论和给任何想要报案性侵的女性的建议是——带上证据。
I just think that all of the facts and everything needs to be laid out so that they can't go back and find something, you know, that you didn't tell them.
我只是认为所有事实和一切都需要摆出来，这样他们就无法回头找点东西，你知道，你没告诉他们的。
I know, but you're not on trial.
我知道，但你不是被告。
Oh, I know. Right. I'm not really sure how to answer that. It just seems like that's how everybody is. Really sucks that you have to be on trial after you go through something so traumatic like that. But that's just how it is and how people think. And that's what happened to me.
哦，我知道。对了。我不太确定该怎么回答。这看起来就像每个人都是这样。当你经历过如此创伤的事情后还要像在审判一样，真的很烂。但这确实就是那样，也是人们的想法。那也是发生在我身上的。
This story was put together by Ken Armstrong and Robyn Semien. Robyn is a producer on our program. Ken is an investigative reporter for The Marshall Project. A print version of the story, a collaboration between The Marshall Project and ProPublica, was published in December. You can read that online at themarshallproject.org or propublica.org. That version of the story was reported and written by Ken and ProPublica's T. Christian Miller, who also contributed to the radio version of the story.
这个故事由肯·阿姆斯特朗和罗宾·塞米恩组合完成。罗宾是我们节目的制作人。肯是《马歇尔计划》的调查记者。该故事的印刷版，由《马歇尔计划》和《ProPublica》合作，于 12 月发布。你可以在 themarshallproject.org 或 propublica.org 在线阅读。该版本的故事由肯和《ProPublica》的 T. 克里斯蒂安·米勒报道和撰写，他也对广播版本的故事做出了贡献。
[MUSIC - AMY BLACK, "SHADOW OF DOUBT"]
[音乐 - 艾米·布莱克，《怀疑的阴影》]
Well, our program was produced today by Brian Reed, Robyn Semien with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our editor's Joel Lovell. Julie Snyder's our editorial consultant. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from Lyra Smith. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our business operations manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for our program. Kimberly Henderson is our office coordinator. Research help from Christopher Swetala. Music help Damien Gray, from Geddis.
嗯，我们的节目今天由布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩制作，还有佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、斯蒂芬妮·富、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、阿丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制作人是布莱恩·里德。我们的编辑是乔尔·洛弗尔。朱莉·斯奈德是我们的编辑顾问。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。制作协助来自莱拉·史密斯。塞斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的业务运营经理。埃尔娜·贝克为我们的节目搜寻故事。金伯利·亨德森是我们的办公室协调员。研究协助来自克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉。音乐协助戴米恩·格雷，来自格迪斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I asked him, why is he so beloved? Is it because he's so great at his job? Or is he just so good-looking.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》通过 PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，我问他，为什么他如此受欢迎？是因为他工作太出色了吗？还是因为他长得太帅了。
Crap. It could be either one, really.
糟了。确实可能是其中任何一个。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。
[MUSIC - ANNE WEISS, "SHADOW OF DOUBT"]
[音乐 - 安妮·韦斯，《怀疑的阴影》]